dress on you know Phil's comments real
quick about it and he just said you know
glad that he mentioned pentament he said
I see these games being a pair because a
smaller projects from larger novellas to
larger developers I'm just wondering how
successful the question was how these
projects would have been for you and
whether you see them fitting in the
ecosystem and then pretty much he goes
into saying like creating that creative
Outlet gazing success he's saying
internally he loves to give the the
outlet to creators and opportunities and
see this is the positive now about the
hands quote unquote the hands off so to
speak because you allow them to create
what they want to create and we had Gene
Park on where he interviewed Neil
druckman and Neil druckman said this
with no he's like one of the best things
developing you come up with some of your
best things when you are actually
passionate and allowed to make what you
want but sometimes you're you're
shoveled or boxed in to just being
formulate like when we had Jason Rubin
on right Jason Rubin as much as he's the
OG naughty dog he did crash he did you
know Jackson Dexter after a while the
success became so busy